but I think that that that having a
conversation
um
just shows you how many people were
understanding that yes we do have
socialism in this country socialism for
the rich and I'll give you an example
the the the the first kind of economic
experiment that people learn in this
country is a lemonade stand for little
kids right let me show you why this is
deceptive and part of the reason
capitalism is failing you
the little kid is out there selling
Dollar Glasses of lemonade
you haven't bought the lemons kid your
mommy did just like the government buys
stuff for these big companies you didn't
buy the knife that you cut the lemons
with a matter of fact you probably
didn't even cut the lemons you don't own
the pitcher you don't own the house you
never paid the water bill you didn't
bring the table outside right and you're
not going to clean everything up when
it's over so you are the exemplifying
precise example of what the American
corporation does which is live off the
welfare of the state to make money for
itself and meanwhile you're fighting
imaginary communism when it's just
corporatism you don't even have to
imagine Illuminati imagine the corporate
Board of Kmart they'll give you as much
access to what they're talking about as
Illuminati will you're not invited into
that boardroom you're not invited into
the boardroom where they say oh we can't
sell these products because they have
high fructose corn syrup I just came
back from a tour in Europe they're at
they don't even sell American Products
there because they say that they cause
cancer and they're crazy and another
thing you could buy a doctor just as
easily as you can buy a politician
ladies and gentlemen which is what the
FDA does here in this country